welcome everybody to a quick video in a
new series called this is now a thing
you can do probably something like that
on making interpolation videos with
stable diffusion like the one playing
right now
so stable diffusion is put super simply
a text to image generation ai which runs
on only a few gigs of memory and which
all by itself is absolutely insane given
the vast number and types of imagery
that it can create effectively having
compressed
like countless terabytes of imagery down
to just a few gigs uh that's that's
incredible but maybe more on that later
for now we can make images of just about
whatever we want but from this model's
inherent capabilities and understanding
of language and text and mapping that to
pictures one of the more interesting
things that we can do is interpolate
between two or more images
to do this i'll be using a package from
nate raw on github which makes this
whole process a breeze to to do this
package is also in active development
and i am sure many things will be
changing and improving over time so uh
if there especially with something in
like my workflow my guess is things will
change and will be added to that package
and you won't have to do it exactly as
arduously as i have so first of all we
need two or more images to start with to
shift between my personal workflow has
been to come up with a prompt and then
generate 50 to 100 or a few hundred
images with randomly selected seeds and
then manually review the images and pick
the ones that i think would be cool to
use i'll put a gist or something like
that in the description so you can copy
me but at some point i think in the near
future i really expect this package from
nate raw to contain a lot of this
workflow for you so you don't have to be
doing this like separately
so for images that you go with you can
do whatever you want for me i think
things that work most obviously
are anything that like grows or changes
over time and then stitch those things
together so things like cities or maybe
like a story or an evolution of
something over time that sort of thing i
think makes a whole lot of sense one of
the things i really wanted to do was
like a music video and it's funny
because i was talking with nate raw and
that was one of the things he even
suggested but it's like um i like my
youtube channel so i can't do that
but i think that would be a really cool
application i just don't think i just
can't do it so anyways uh instead i
decided to just go with an example of a
porsche 911 model uh over the years so
from 1965 to current but i encourage you
to try all kinds of crazy things because
there's there's so many like unique and
fascinating things that you can do
because you don't it doesn't have to be
a thing that grows over time or it
doesn't even have to be two things that
are even related you could interpolate
between a car and a dog if you wanted
and that might be pretty cool to see so
i encourage you guys to really kind of
tinker around and try to be creative
with it um like i said all this stuff
runs on very like you don't need that
beefy of a gpu like 10 gigs ish is all
you need so um definitely and you can
even get by with less than that so
anyway first i have a script that runs
through a list of prompts then for each
prompt it iterates through and in this
case 200 examples each with a randomly
selected seed from there each image is
generated with stable diffusion and it's
saved in a directory with the name of
the prompt and then the name of the
actual image in that directory is the
seed that was used to generate that
image
then i just look through the images and
either select the ones that i want or i
come up with another prompt or try some
more seeds until i have a good sequence
of images that i want to make a video
out of from here we can use this stable
diffusion videos package to go through
and interpolate between all of these
making pretty cool videos one of the
more recent modifications to this
package was the addition of an upscaler
which you can use by just adding upscale
equals true in your walk command and
then also installing the real esr gan
package this is just a general upscaler
so it may not work precisely for the
task or the the type of imagery that
you're attempting to use it for but it's
there if you want it and it will get you
from 512 by 512 imagery to 2048 by 2048.
so go forth and create also right now i
have a ceo of nvidia jensen signed 3090
ti to be given away all you need to do
to be eligible is to sign up for free
for gtc the all digital nvidia gpu and
ai oriented conference and all you need
to do is sign up using the link in the
description and you just have to attend
one or more sessions the 3090ti is an
absolute beast of a card so
congratulations in advance for whoever
gets it i am jealous of you and the
signed box is a just cool piece of
history honestly anyway that's all for
now hopefully you guys have enjoyed the
shorter-ish format of videos there are
so many like little projects that are
kind of coming out and things that you
can do with
ai like stable diffusion it's not just
stable diffusion stuff there's other
stuff as well um i don't really think it
would be great to just like throw them
all in like one giant video and then
each one is not really
big enough for like a full feature
length um a full 40 minute syntax video
so let me know what you think about the
shorter format uh also if you make your
own stable diffusion interpolation
videos please put them down in the
comments i'd be really interested to see
what other people are coming up with uh
with this sort of like technology
because there's so much room for
creativity here and i just i'm super
curious to see what other people come up
with so anyway that's all for now thanks
for watching and i will see you all in
another video
you